hey hey hey you what did the horse say
to the UM other to the chicken on
Christmas hey hey hey
so today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza if you want something
and you can't and you think you can have
it and it's pizza then you're doing
great
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach gray block get that hitter merry
Christmas to you
merry Christmas to you
[Music]
Oh
kanima stay waiting now
romance will be sitting
the Andrew
and that is some romance modern jazz
Christmas there by Bluma Patterson and
that is Bellomo Patterson there with a
song called Christmas moment let me pull
up something else that's really let me
pull a fire up another here here we go
one right here
oh yeah this at Wild West
get on your horse get a gun and get some
dang Christmas
[Music]
Banna
for Santa
[Music]
Bering Strait
and that is a song right there that is a
tomato Misha Alexander with Santa hold
on
happy holidays you merry Christmas to
you and that's what I say a lot of time
Merry Christmas and that's how I leave
it oh it's that time of year is good to
be here I hope that you are just
honestly I hope you're wherever you are
I don't care what I don't wherever you
are I hope you really fired up about it
and you feeling that you'll baby you
feeling that you'll you know because
this is that time when you can just you
know you could kind of grab somebody's
cheek a little and wit and I'll wiggle
it AAA buddy
Merry Christmas this time when you could
pet a little you know pet a neighbor's
son touch them on the head hey buddy
you're doing great you know stay out of
my yard but you're doing great it's that
time it's that holiday time you know and
it's it's really when you think about
Christmas that they had a baby in the
desert and I've talked about this before
but they had a baby in the desert first
of all very dangerous I don't have you
ever been Arizona but you don't see a
lot of babies a lot of children won't
even come out of the the the homesteads
or the buildings until they're five six
when they got enough hydration in him
they got him oiled up enough because a
baby at the desert is the complete
opposite of a baby you know what baby is
um his isla it's like good she kind of
and got fat like a little it's fat
looked like muscle
you know a lot of time you'll see a baby
and its fat look like muscle you'll see
a lot of its arms look like he's jacked
but he's only 20 pounds you know like
damn is he Jack no he's just he's just
he's fat but he's it's stylish the fat
is never as stylish on us as it is when
we're a child and the desert is dry it's
grainy it's sound like that it doesn't
there's nothing slick about it so a baby
if you put a baby in the desert man it's
lights out so to think that a long time
ago for Christmas that a baby was born
and put in the desert land and and then
a bunch of men went out there to see him
and that's where it really does get wild
I get you know I get but I also if I
think if somebody said hey man I got a
baby out in the desert think about that
you're somewhere you know you're at a
Hardee's or you're somewhere you know
you're just parked in your truck
somewhere just thinking about your wife
or something or or anything you know
doing whatever you're doing video games
whatever and you and somebody nudges
you're something a buddy they got a baby
in the desert
would go see it you would go see it
that's an easy one some people maybe
Chris D'Elia would be like I ain't gonna
see that baby you know but but any
regular you know mentally decent mail
would go see that baby and so that's
what's beautiful about the story of
Christmas is they had a baby in the
desert some people went out there a
couple donkeys went out there and [ __ ]
got real sentimental and and that's
beautiful man and that's it and here we
are fast forwarding to the year 2019 and
this thing is wrapping up this year's
almost wrapped up like a gift it's like
we're wrapping the gift ourselves as the
year ends and I can't even remember
what's in the box
sometimes the years go by so fast I
can't even you know life is such a time
capsule sometime I don't know what's in
it
and I'm sitting there putting things in
it all the time but yet I don't even
know what's in it and before I can get a
try and get a handle on it it starts
back again it's all genuine Orellana
Larry and so a lot of my Latino friends
say here on your winery
Oh pom-pom don't you like yarn you a tea
and some people think all those races to
do a Mexican I said it's not racist dude
I love a Mexican accent and it's fun do
what Mexican accent do a Chinese accent
do a white guy accent do a freakin that
girl you know who's always like with the
long thing I do I do it do it do
whatever you want
it's an accent so do it oh ho ho that's
an accent that's an oh hey hey hey that
is a pervert right there boy if you hear
somebody like that if somebody has a
couple grams of coke and they say
there's a baby in the
now that's different that's danger but
if somebody comes over and nudges you
during holiday say hey big boy
they got a baby in Las Elias then you're
gonna go for that you better go for that
what else what's going on not too much
I'm flying back to Louisiana tomorrow
and I'm just looking forward to it
you know I'm gonna go do the deal give
me a little bit of gumbo give me a
little bit of Christmas young Malaya
jambalaya and they'll put anything in
yon Malaya dude somebody of jambalaya
might have a little swallow in it and
all if you've ever had swallow or not
it's not I don't need it around children
and it's really an adult meat because if
children you know if children hear you
eatin attractive birds they get nervous
you know so if you have that swallow
that's something you know that's more of
a seasonal or you know a special time of
year when you have a little bit of
swallow but until you but that's
something in my jambalaya you could hide
something you're not sure if you want to
eat inside of something you do you know
you could throw a few Jolly Ranchers in
there you know you could throw a couple
marshmallows down there in the middle
bamm-bamm what's that oh this is good oh
it's just got crabmeat all down this is
sweet
that's the marshmallows bro and that's a
young I am oh yeah my lat
what's going on man it's the end of the
year and it's been a great year I want
to thank everybody for the support had
some good podcast recently we got some
great ones coming up in the new year
that's going to be exciting I'm going we
got the show in Lafayette coming up let
me let you know a couple dates that are
still available January 14th in Oslo
Norway January 15
Stockholm Sweden January 31st and
February 1st Las Vegas Nevada and that's
at the Mirage coming back through a
Super Bowl weekend so if you're going to
be there come see February 15th
Oroville casino at the Gold Country
February 20th Toronto
Queen Elizabeth Theatre and we just
opened Thursday night tickets for that
week as well and then February 28th Oxon
Hill Maryland or that makeup show from
last year and it's beautiful here on the
set if you could see what producer Nick
is done man man and we got we got some
beautiful people give us some Christmas
ornaments Rat King
damn we are very blessed to be part of
such a wonderful group I'm going to let
you know - we got some single moms that
are going to come out into Lafayette and
here's a submission that came in for one
want you guys to uh to get on board here
we go hey what's up Co this is Jess from
Crowley Louisiana think this past
weekend fangs and gang buzzbuzz gang
Jeffrey and thank you for calling over
there on Crowley and Crowley's a kind of
place they got big animals over there
you'll see an inchworm that's for damn
two feet long you're like whoa this
fella
this fellow might be in the rodeo you
know they're big so it's that kind of
place home where Jeffrey um I was
calling to nominate my mom for single
mothers night at your show in Lafayette
Louisiana she's a single mother on the
five boys she always worked hard for us
growing up trying to provide for us
everything she can you know tour with a
lot of kids like that and she know how
much was socialized to get out much you
know she can't do much to work nights
but she's got her dream job as a nurse
and Lafayette and she's a she's a big
fan of the show me and all my brothers
we watch you and we love you came your
show in Biloxi Mississippi you know
coming coming close to its in Lafayette
and I know my mom would love to
be able to get a night out and go enjoy
herself and you know do her own thing so
yeah hope you uh hope it's all back well
look man you're very welcoming yeah I'm
so excited that she's going to come now
we will reach out to you we got a couple
single moms we're gonna have them and a
guest join us for dinner before the show
and and we're gonna do something nice
for them as well so Jeff will reach out
thank you that's very sweet of you man
and you know it's um you know you think
about that you think about if they had
you know when you know what mothers got
to do a lot of it on her own and just
the fear that probably comes but that
they push it aside real quick you know
their stories a mother could lift a damn
ship a robe off a [ __ ] set of twins
or something they'll have a 700 pound
shiver robe and uh something happens
there's lightning or something or a
little you know maybe something hits
your house or knocks it over onto a kid
and a mother lift it off of them and
this is a mother that you know it could
be a mother that's never done squats or
never even you know she an old creatine
or any type of you know pre-workout and
then suddenly they'll be able to just
have the strength you know sometimes if
we could just crack open a mother and
just get what it just had just harness
whatever that is that strength of love
and of perseverance that they have man
it's something
beautiful that's it's it's own little
Christmas man what goes on inside of a
mother and I applaud your mother Jeff
and I am excited to get to meet her so
her and a guest will be coming up well
please join us for dinner I hope you
will Nikhil reach out to you and and we
will set it up and we got a couple of
others we're gonna reach out that we had
a we had a good deal of single moms that
were nominated and we can't have
everybody out but we're gonna have some
out and we're gonna do our best and the
next ones will catch next time so thank
you very much for the submissions oh man
it's that time of year dude I was
thinking man one Christmas I got I got a
silk shirt and I don't know if you ever
remember the silk shirt cuz silk is
first something you think you'll never
be able to have it cuz spiders have it
and there's no if you look at a spider
never once does a spider look like hey
I'm gonna [ __ ] do something for you
you know almost share this batch with
you you know and it's marvelous that
sometimes one you know that want that
that at some point in history I don't
know when or whatever but they made a
deal with them and they got all the silk
so we when I remember when I got a silk
shirt I just it blew my mind and I don't
know if you remember when these really
hit the market they were kind of they
had that kind of cloth one edge to him
like it one it was like mine was like a
light red like a light red shirt and
from straight on it looked red but if
you stood had somebody move over about
five inches to the right or the left and
look at it it looked a little bit purple
it was just you know like when you see
some of these cars been leaking oil on
your on the concrete outside of your
house from and you'll see a little bit
of they have the oil and then on top of
the oil they got that little uh that
little party layer you know that kind of
little it's like a little like somebody
just beat the [ __ ] out of a rainbow when
just left it there bleeding kinda well
it's like that and that's the kind of
thing that's in the silk it has this
really trans vessel thing I don't know
what it is it's like an extra layer of
skin in it that kind of glistens that's
ready to [ __ ] party or do something
blow and I remember I got that silk
shirt and man it was nice dude I
remember when we knock came back from
this to school from Christmas that's
when I really hit my stride because
that's when I had that new stuff I had
that Flex you know I had the freakin
straight-up just flex curtains for a new
shirt new hat you know some time in
winter me and my brother split a pair of
mittens he get one one day I get one the
next you know he's going left I'm going
right bro you feel me and then sometime
I'd replace the other side I get a oven
mitt cuz um my dad you know whenever my
parents were married he would say my mom
is drinking he got my mother a set of
small oven mitts one time when he was in
I think like Puerto Rico or something
and so we had some time you could
replace the other Goldmann you didn't
have with that [ __ ] baby oven mitt
but yeah that shirt man that silk shirt
so I go back to school with anything I
knew I got fresh hanging off of me
anything slap bracelet new wrestling
figurine have it in my pocket
my grandma give me a bag of mints
usually she'd give me a bag of breath
mints I was her big thing and I would
just roll to school rough I can mint it
up pocket full of the Ultimate Warrior
gang [ __ ] and I had that silk I had that
[ __ ] the spider spit
a smock on and and that thing
man it was nice and the crazy thing was
though if you started sweating the sweat
would immediately get so then the shirts
started to stick to you and in Louisiana
you sweat automatically it doesn't
matter it'd be 200 degrees below zero
and everybody sweat you nope it just
gets hot down there you'll see a crab
sometime you'll see a crab come out of
his shell and he's wiping his brown the
man is hot in there you see it
Louisiana's just like that you know
you'll see a raccoon take off his fur
and hang it on the branch for a bed you
know he'll be over there just ringing
out his muscles full of sweat and a -
you seen a furless comb brother you
don't know what's up man you're like
damn bruh but those I remember those
silk shirts and then sometime like that
thing would get all when it got sweaty
would just stick to you but yeah if you
looked at it head on it was green but if
you had somebody move nine inches over
to the left and look at it it was like a
little bit a little bit less green kind
of blue or something man I love those I
love that silk shirt back in the day we
got some calls came in nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three Merry
Christmas to you and Happy Holidays to
you and and we got a great bright year
coming up ahead of us all of us you know
we are living this gift of life man and
it and it is a journey and I'm grateful
that it is a journey I'm grateful that
it is highs and lows because it is a
challenge you know I mean if you played
Super Mario and it was just the whole
course was just you running to the end
man you put the controller down after
one time
but it's not like that you know life is
there's more they got the magic
mushrooms they got you know you can get
a little bit of coin you know you can
beat your head into some bricks you know
you can you know so every now and then
do it in certain areas bro you could
light a can of wd-40 and throw it throw
it at somebody who [ __ ] didn't fix
your truck correctly you know fireballs
you know they got dragons you can fight
every now and then it some thought will
come out the house with a bunch of
slippers on talking [ __ ] and you could
freaking you know just launch that [ __ ]
off a drawbridge if you want I mean I'm
just saying that it's as tough as it is
some time with these downs and these
valleys that are in life we wouldn't
play if it were if it wasn't challenged
we wouldn't play we would I wouldn't
play I don't think so I'm not preaching
at you I'm just trying to remind myself
that that this is the game this is the
this is this is the game I'm playing you
know in an easier a too easy game there
would be no challenge and I get to see
Who I am when there's a challenge around
me and and it's nice it's nice to be
it's nice to be inspired even by
ourselves sometimes in the face of
adversity
but all right let's get into a couple
calls that came in ninety five six six
four nine five zero three don't what's
up the old Jake Tennessee I work with
the post office and what's up Big Jake
at the post office that Pio and dude
yeah I know a lot of y'all hopped up on
them perfume samples dude I know that
[ __ ] that's why I go in there sometime
I'll see some dude like he's on some
damn you know polo sport I'm like damn
bro you need to you know you'll see him
over in the distance just ripping open a
magazine and getting hit getting a
couple hits at Burberry Brit over there
you're like doing
you freakin better back off that
Christiaan Jia cuz you [ __ ] geeked up
dog yeah one time the guy pushing the
little mail card he's over there you saw
him he's back there he's ripping perfume
samples out of the scenes and [ __ ]
basting under his own bra you know he
hits himself with them samples and next
thing you know he's all tweaked out cuz
he's popped up because he's been you
know scenting up his trenches brah I'm
telling you that's one danger thing
about being at the post office is get
whatever comes through the mail try not
to get addicted to it and that is nature
that's nurture that's nature or nurture
so can we beat it I don't know yeah one
time the mail truck is over by my house
it's a list 11 o'clock at night I go out
there I'm looking at the guy he's in
there he's got he's got two strips of
estee lauder
cut up in a little paper squares and
he's putting them under his tongue I
said oh he bout to smell the devil but
that's you know that's just the dangers
of working in the UH in the mailing
catalog industry but thank you for
calling brother Lestat let's hear more
today I I was at his house delivering
the packages our new routes I don't
really know this house now walk up drop
off this big box and do what they had a
snack bucket for all like delivery
drivers and stuff that come to your
house during you know Christmas time
especially during Black Friday Cyber
Monday
these people have nice snacks out there
and stuff and I'm not gonna like you I
forgot about my delivery drivers and
other [ __ ] but I just want to give a PSA
to all these people here don't forget
about your delivery trucks you know
they're bringing you all your Amazon
dildos or whatever you're ordering
online he'll show my nipple with some
yeah don't forget about the delivery
drivers this Christmas Saul wants a gang
yeah
let's get it gang gang let's get it and
that man right there is telling the
truth right there out there out of
Tennessee take care of your drivers
these men out there they schlep in this
a net you ordered 13 boxes of oatmeal
for your grandmother for Christmas and
now you know Henry over here he's got to
slap it up the stairs for you leave him
something out front leave him a thing of
fresh Dorito packages or leaving me um a
thing of gummy bears man or you can even
get that one big gummy bear that big
[ __ ] man that big papa bear that
thing's about freaking probably eleven
and a half inches tall and he can just
snack on that [ __ ] while he's cruising
around yeah people think they disorder
off Amazon it magically drops on their
doorway no they got a middleman they got
these sidepiece Santa's running around
everywhere and those men and women too a
lot of strong whim women who also do
fitness and who be having protein shakes
on her lunch break and wearing gloves
with no fingers on you know I'm talking
about a lot of strong you know sometimes
lesbian and sometimes non lesbian women
that dress like the Wet Bandits from
home alone and these beautiful ladies
over there slepping the goods up to your
door so leave them something out there
these are the real Santa's leave them on
milk leave them with cookie leave them a
picture of you and your cousin or
something doing you know fish and
catching a big trout catching a big
walleye ta Oh baby just think about
others and you know it thank you for
calling and thank you for making all
those deliveries and I'm gonna think
about it to almost set a little stool
out there dear mr. FedEx dear mr. Amazon
dear mr. or mrs. mail person I know
you're really Santa
and here's a rice krispies treat from my
nice crispy heart gang brother homeward
I got to tell you this you know it and I
know it that this episode is brought to
you by better help better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you know we do live in a time where a
lot of men is getting in need of help
and women of brain help and you can
start communicating with a therapist in
under 24 hours with better help there's
a broad range of expertise
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional therapy
you know I go to I've used better help
where you you know you can be enough you
can text a therapist you can call you
can do video chat Skype there's ways to
get help without having to drive over to
that office in town that have that
stigma and they got one man out there
you know maybe a brother maybe a couple
of uh you know a white dude wearing like
a buffalo sabres Jersey or something and
they you know having a couple freaking
menthols or blowing a Winston and you
know that they trying to just score a
couple of um of of drugs from a
therapist or something you know some of
them buy the building and you don't
you're like oh I'm not going there
somebody gonna see me needing help
what better help offers you a way to do
that without driving over visit better
help calm slash Theo that's B e TT er H
ELP and join over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
that's right special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month so you can do that at better help
calm slash Theo Oh what's going on man I
don't know I'm excited down in Lafayette
we're gonna raise some money for Dustin
Poirier charity the good fight
foundation
that show I think it's sold out people
are asking about a meet-and-greet there
will be one after and we're excited to
raise some money for Dustin's charity
you know they help people that can't
help themselves and and that's one of
the things that this whole podcast kind
of was started on his [ __ ] I don't
know man whatever dog I mean not
whatever but I'm just glad I'm not
freaking laying in a park trying to
smoke my own nuts right now cuz sums up
somebody somebody's doing that bro
grilling body you feel me let's have a
little bit of her own grilled body and I
knew a man that brings me I knew a man
this dude is Swaney up there and uh in
mountain near Natchez Mississippi and he
actually he took his own wiener off of
his body with a knife at a party when he
was on LSD and um and they used to run
the Ramada over there on the bluffs but
anyway all right let's take another call
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three as always as the hotline oh
and this is I think our three-year
anniversary - that's crazy this is three
years I'll talk about that in a minute
here we go what's up there's Josh from
home you know I just call that gonna
both die
went to depression if you ever get that
you know I just remember you looking
[ __ ] our way don't sir yes I do Josh
thank you for calling I do live in LA
Oliver brother window [ __ ] window
over there do it you know I'm saying
you don't get no sewing up then I work
at what happens over well does it get
cold
you know that's a good question what
happens over here during the holiday and
I'm gonna answer it in a second let's
hear more from you no [ __ ] nosy you
know I'm driving around [ __ ] it's true
snow right now and then haven't seen my
50 days you know because I've been
pleased to learn in a cooler you know
one of them igloo hitters as you know
right back up that's delivering those
packages bro that's what I'm talking
about brother 28 degree drywall baby
that's a gluon gang FedEx don't give a
[ __ ] if it's Mellon you know person you
lot got to get after but yeah so you
know what I mean
questions still stand cuz you know maybe
you wear some like old one
I'm sure you were you've been a lot of
places look a great question brother i
we don't have a it doesn't get cold here
and you know one thing about Los Angeles
that really freaking trickles my dick oh
bruh I mean this will make me it just
leaked from my low beak and that is that
that there's no seasons here so things
don't change so there's no you don't
feel the vibe you don't feel that Mother
Nature has a real pulse here you know
you don't feel her wrath that much you
know there's fire sometime but that's
usually a dude over there you know some
dude playing hopscotch what is it with
his buddy and they're all cooked up on
that fricking on that kettle corn
you know methamphetamine and next thing
you know they'll [ __ ] they chasing
each other with cigarettes playing you
know P P tag or whatever out there
behind the bushes
you know when it's kind of drug-induced
homosexuality and next thing you know
they burned down half of a [ __ ]
hillside because these bastards over
there doing you know gramming up on the
[ __ ] some homemade cher Nobles over
there and I'll tweaked out on that
Buster dustless and next thing you know
they don't they they who knows so they
burned on a hillside with half a Winston
because they fall asleep in each others
arms over there all cooked out on that
[ __ ] bugle bully
but Jesus sorry I'm wearing a bad
Christmas hat and earphones at the same
time um
are we talking about okay there's no
winter here and one thing is so that's
what sometimes when one of the reasons
why people in Los Angeles are so nutty
is because they don't they they feel
like they run the world Mother Nature
doesn't push anything on them you know
so they feel more powerful than nature a
lot of times you know there's not
there's no season so things never you
don't realize the power of Mother Nature
you don't realize the beauty of just you
get trapped in this bubble that things
can just go on forever as the same or I
think so this is just what I think sorry
this isn't everybody uh-huh but other
places yeah you realize okay for four
months I'm gonna be have to be indoors
you know I so maybe I should find our
spouse I'm gonna need someone not just
just that I can hook up with for a night
I need somebody to care about I need
somebody to care about me you know
winter's coming
you know I know in the Midwest they got
cuffing season and that's when if you
don't have someone to love you got a
lock on now and and so in the winter a
lot of times that cuffing season is
right there around August September
October and that's when you better lock
down a mate because it's gonna get cold
and you need that [ __ ] that full-body
during that full-body dural log you know
a significant other and they have it man
they are so so so uh so that's one thing
about LA use there's no effective nature
I don't feel like as much with the
weather now that's strictly the weather
you can see the power of nature by going
to the beach and there's you know
there's a very peaceful element but you
don't see it from the weather where the
weather really dictates things it
doesn't rain so you can always throw a
party you could plan anything you never
have to worry about the weather like I
never wake up in the morning and think
what the weather will be but when I used
to work on Mississippi over there on a
farm we use to have to look at the DTN
all day I think that's what
was called DTM weather yeah we'd have to
look at the DTN and his back for they
had an app when you had to look at the
actual computer screen go in there and
see where the storms were coming across
so you say okay we could fertilize right
here today because it's gonna be dry you
know or it's okay to have a crop duster
come through today because because it's
you know it's not gonna rain so we're
not gonna you know lose whatever
chemical we put down um but I remember
that having to just sit at the DTN and
weather would dictate how you behaved
but here it doesn't happen as much so
yeah I think it's a lot of people in
California in Los Angeles go to Hawaii
you know they're like they want an even
nicer which is another thing I noticed
why this city doesn't stop much man in
Louisiana when it rains if a time out
talk to your buddy sit on the porch
spend some time we can't go do something
it's raining when it snows are we snowed
in I mean maybe you have two friends
come over and you guys enjoy each
other's company because you need it you
know there's more of a value on one
another but this is more of a turnstile
out here and I'm not saying damn la blah
blah blah there's a lot of great things
but I am answering the question as to
how this what do I feel like the weather
dictates behavior here in LA you know
there's less like in a lot of places you
help somebody shovel their driveway an
opportunity to talk somebody hey hey
Berta hey miss Berta let me go do your
shovel you know my buddy over there he
used to go decorate the Christmas tree
by the neighbor and she would [ __ ]
touch his ass while he was on the ladder
what are you gonna do huh it's Christmas
but stay busy out there if you FedEx and
baby get it done and put something out
on your porch for a FedEx erse put some
money a porch for Amazon guy you know
they're gonna stop by let them you know
it does feel feeling appreciated is nice
isn't it yang oh let's get a call right
here here we go what's up do this Jake
will San Diego was so Jay from San Diego
man thank you for calling brother
homeward down here in the dirty
breakfast just calling to give you one
of those hot line hitters that you love
recently all social media I've been
seeing a lot of stuff about you people
trying to change Santa Claus gender to
be gender-neutral or you know
questioning whether he may or not may or
may not be a woman and I'm like the man
has a beard it's kind of wondering where
you stand on the whole subject night do
you think it's as funny as idea flirt I
mean no okay gang Jake thanks for the
message if you and your household want
to have a nondescript universe that's
fine but I like Santa being a woman his
wife is mrs. Claus you know the Tooth
Fairy is a gay man the the Easter Bunny
could be a woman now that I could see
let's go either way with it but Santa is
a man Santa is a man if you you don't
want some ladies being out all night it
doesn't feel even safe you know a lot of
women get to you know taking advantage
of at night and Santa is just you can't
and you won't some that [ __ ] man people
that is dumb but nobody's buying that
[ __ ]
well Santa does another Jew Santa is a
man okay until he comes out and shows a
tit or busts out a lip that's a man and
that's it and it's really just the same
because here's what happens if is if
that's all fuel by companies if they can
make it if they can make Santa Santa
generate gender neutral then they can
sell a whole new branch of new Santa
ornaments new Santa Christmas card new
Santa pool toys because now they got the
gender-neutral Santa and so that's you
have to for me I think that's where a
lot of that motivation comes from is all
it's just people trying to make money
it's people trying to make money and
it's sad man it's sad and I try to
distance myself from things where I feel
like that is what it is only about but
yeah [ __ ] that's some [ __ ] dude
nobody want their grandmother out there
driving a sleigh all night do my mom's
driving a freakin Houston right now and
she called me nine times and it's only
2:00 in the afternoon but nobody nobody
want that grandma out there slapping
around a bunch of Hello kitties or
whatever you know what bunch of you know
um Gryffindor hats or whatever the
children want this year and now she you
know your grandmother's got to stay at a
Days Inn cuz one of the reindeers she's
worried about him overheat no you want
Santa out there Manta bruh you want him
with the pedal to the metal on dancer on
Prancer vixen stayed up all night doing
some dust oh well put him on your back
Cupid cuz we ride in
what if a couple of Somali pirates show
up in the middle of the night and you
got a gender-neutral Santa Clause out
here injecting himself with different
hormones and [ __ ] many nobody's getting
a gift cuz they're Jack he's getting you
know no kids are getting gifts now you
can't do it like that
Santa's not a woman nobody wants him to
be a woman it's some [ __ ] writing an
article who isn't who doesn't have any
care about you know a lot of people they
want to kill any Christian spirit that's
alive and they want to kill the fun
don't let these people kill your fun
they're just trying to take advantage
you and make money and get out of here
with that man Santa's a man the earth
mother earth the earth is a woman Tooth
Fairy is a gay man everybody gots their
space you know this [ __ ] ever since
black auntie nobody likes black auntie
even my black friends are like what so
unless it should have had Blake Griffin
in it then it would have been good he's
hilarious
but let's be real with this [ __ ] man I'm
tired of it because some of it there's
no benefit to it it's just a trick to
sell oh if we can make every man think
they're a woman then we could sell them
all now woman products as well so I'm
all about equality but you know
everything functions because there's a
male female there's yin and yang now I'm
not saying there might be you know the
gestation in three generations we might
all be you know we might all be by
gender who knows but let nature do that
not some [ __ ] with a yahoo article
gang bro sorry I got heated I'm gonna
tell you about this man
I'm going to tell you about Beck's
sunglasses do you care about your eyes
bro
ask yourself down in your and your
little cauldron of a feeling and hope
that's your heart ask yourself do you
care about your eyes because your eyes
are just little visual hearts that are
just kind of poking out of your face a
little bit with my lifestyle and the Sun
here in California I need sunglasses
that will hold up Beck's sunglasses B
e^x our beautiful and talented polarized
sunglasses that are tough
that's me hitting them right there and
clear as hell Beck's makes me feel like
the Sun can't handle me Beck's makes me
feel like I would take the Sun on a date
and not even blink
their light rugged polarized sunglasses
they're made with luxury materials by
the finest craftsmanship in the world
Beck's sunglasses perform under the
harshest conditions rain hail lava alien
buy your sunglasses from Beck's
sunglasses calm that's B e ex su in GLA
SS es calm and use code Theo for 20% off
your entire order that's right by your
sunglasses from be e ex sunglasses
dot-com and use code Theo for 20% off
your entire order yeah these are Hardy
today's
episode is also brought to you by a
butcher box everybody want that meat you
know they probably got a couple ladies
trying to slide into my snapchats right
now saying they want that meat visit you
know they want that door-to-door bacon
burrito well back off ladies what I'm
telling you is this butcher box is the
one you need butcher box has a box full
of beautiful priceless meet every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high quality meat right to my home the
meat is free of antibiotics some people
you see their meat it's it's been taking
a z-pack you know you'll get a thing of
pork rolls and half of them tastes like
a you know zithromax erythromycin each
box has nine to eleven pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals you can
eat for almost a month off a box it's
packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed it is my freezer right now
is full of butcher box treats they got
finished beef none of that unfinished
beef you know I'm saying you get a
splinter from [ __ ]
they got free-range organic chicken they
have heritage pork and wild caught
Alaskan salmon and sugar nitrate free
bacon it's the way meat should be right
now you can get two pounds of ground
beef and two packs of bacon absolutely
free plus 20% off your first box just go
to butcher box.com slash Theo or use
promo code th EO at checkout
that's butcher box.com slash th EO or
use promo code Theo
at checkout if you like having meat in
your home and you do not want to have to
go and get it all the time this is a
perfect solution I didn't even like dude
I would hate going if ma was with my mom
and I had on a tank top
and we was at the grocery bro I was
really a little [ __ ] kid hell I'm half
[ __ ] now most of the time dude you know
me [ __ ] [ __ ] get if I start swimming
in the baby pool of my own damn feelings
I [ __ ] I'll drown down there but but
I'm also a badass dog you know I'll also
put your [ __ ] chubby cousin in a hard
scarf dog I'll put half a bread pudding
in his mouth and [ __ ] put that board
a sugary sleep so don't come out don't
come at me with that [ __ ] I don't even
know what I was talking about okay let's
take another call that came in here here
we go hey Co what up this is Brennan
from Eden Prairie Minnesota
what's up Brennan from Eden Prairie and
Minnesota beautiful um you know I met a
girl one time out there in Minnesota and
she was a Native American she said and
then she accused me of almost oh well
she threatened have a baby with me
anyway
let's hear more for those of you that
don't know he didn't really was
basically the the white bratty little
cousin of Minneapolis and anyways I am
I'm 16 years old by the question about
girls so I got a girl that I like and
she likes me okay this that's a start
man
that is a big start more um but she I
don't know if she's caught up in some of
the illegal activities and I won't get
into that but you know I got my own
issues they'll get again in with all the
pornography's and all that and so
like I said I'm 16 I don't know anything
about girls or life or anything oh and I
I was wondering do you think having a
girlfriend is something that can help
you with your problems or where you can
help each other or is there something
that will distract you from fixing your
problems that need fixing because you
know we both need some fixing and yeah
gang bro thank you for the question
there young fella 16 year old boy
they're calling out of there man
16 hell I'd drink a glass of your blood
if I could man you know it's a man being
16 well here's what I say sometime
relationships can help as soon as they
can hurt I think if if I'm not doing
well then I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to really treat somebody well you
know it's hard to see the value of a
relationship or even a friendship
sometimes when you're in it you know I
can get complacent I'll get complacent
in a relationship sometimes I'll stay in
a relationship just because I'm afraid
to be alone that can happen I mean you
do know some stuff because you are
asking people you know to be 16 and be
this kind of aware and asking these
questions is that's huge dude a lot a
sixteen year olds are just busting on
themselves at home and you at least are
trying to do a little more than that
so I think you know I think if you you
can work on yourselves together you can
work on yourselves apart
and also men you know what sometimes
there's not working on ourselves
sometime it's like you know I'm always
sometimes caught in this I get caught in
this trap sometimes works like I have to
pick I have to repair what something's
wrong and sometimes man I'm just being
alive
I'm just being alive and there's the ups
and the downs but this is the ride it's
almost like I wish they told us that in
school sometimes I had a real course
that said hey children this is what some
days will be like you will leave your
driveway
somebody will you know you'll get a call
from your cousin he'd been in a [ __ ]
head-on collision over there by the
Hardee's you know you'll get to work and
you might lose your job you'll stop on
the way home you'll try to stop by a
Dunkin Donuts and the [ __ ] burned
down and you'll go home and your wife
will be complaining because you guys
haven't had sex in a while sometimes
they should just teach you that day in
school hey that's going to be what
that's what life is sometimes it's that
but so yeah sometimes it just is what it
is and that's the way things are bro so
I think you're going to be fine you're
16 you're figuring it out it's okay take
it easy on yourself you know if this guy
if you're alone if you're not you know
find some things that make you feel good
don't do a bunch of drugs and hurt
yourself bro that's what I'm saying dude
and that pornography can really it'll
dirty your frickin brain and every time
you bust them cheat cheat pops out
you're losing a little bit of that
stallion
so finally you know 19 years from now
you have a child and that [ __ ]
he's a little pony you know he gots a
little buzz cut and he bucking they put
a bell around his neck at the mall and
that's your son so save up those chichi
pops and be a warrior you know save up
those chichi
Thompson be a warrior I don't think I
really helped you or anything but I love
you bro and just take care just just be
safe man where you seatbelt and find
friends that you trust and it's okay if
you don't know what a relationship means
at this point just just do your best and
just know that you're okay man however
you are you're okay
everything is okay you're not doing
anything wrong
the world is not conspiring against you
everything is okay and that's the truth
and I just don't want you thinking that
it's not all the time because I used to
do that and it really was and I can miss
out on some of the beautiful gifts that
are right in front of me let's take a
call right here awkward hey II know this
is Justin from Dallas just on my way
back home from work thought I would
share with you the story that came to my
mind when I was a kid or on the
Christmas time Thank You Dustin or
Justin I'm not sure which one I couldn't
hear it but um it doesn't matter thank
you busting her there man from Dallas
and I love Dallas man and I had a crush
for a while I wanted a radio host
downtown a morning radio gang all work
so me my buddy in Austin were having a
sleepover at his house
oh dang shadow my boy Scott sense feel
when we was younger we stayed by his
daddy's house over there in Jackson
Mississippi and his daddy had a house
over there and it was on the top of a
little bitty hill and we stayed over
there and I'd never slept in bed in a
bed with another man before we wanted
two men who were children
so another you know children man and
and his dad closed the door and then he
came back in about a minute later and he
goes now fellas y'all can sleep pulled a
pole or hold her whole but don't sleep
pole to hold and then he closed the door
and do we sat there for trying to figure
it out and do the math and finally I
just slept on the floor at the foot of
the bed dude like a damn golden
retriever man because we didn't want to
get the equation wrong you know let's
hear more sorry I interrupted your
brother and we I don't know how we got
to this but we went up in his attic we
really just grabbed a bunch of ornaments
and we we filled them up with gasoline
hello gasoline and trailed the little
you know like the cloth outside of the
end we really just made cocktail like
ornament cotton malt hops and we're
really just lighting them up and
throwing in the cards as they went by
and it's pretty risky pretty dangerous
and yeah I mean they really did catch
fire kind of like a bomb so uh yeah I
was swimming I never done anything like
that or just didn't take a risk you over
the holidays appreciate everything you
do getting game thank you brother yeah
I'm little one time we had uh my mother
had a friend that came over and she'd
only come over when we cooked and this
lady was big as a damn I mean just big
as about a small gymnasium and she
really part of her arm and turned a
little yellow because she I don't even
know what had happened something and
anyway she would drive over only way my
mom would cook and she'd come over and
have her she talked and everything and
be friendly but really she was you know
sneaking all of some of the rations she
was really you know she was she she was
there for the food and the the
socializing was second and I remember
one time whilst he was in there we've
gotten some kerosene maybe it was or
gasoline I can't remember
god I love gasoline man I love man I put
some on my hands the other day and just
[ __ ] smelled it all day long
um in any way we put her bumper and
kerosene of her car and right before she
took off we lit that bastion on fire and
she just drove off into the night day
with that with that old-fashioned tail
light baby that Fuego bumper dog and we
lit that we lit that that lady up like
that and honest everywhere mean saw the
lady buried honest lady but I love being
do when I was young we would put [ __ ]
wd-40 on our tongue Braun trying to
[ __ ] lick each other we would do I
love the smell of wd-40
damn dude I love the smell of wd-40 I
wish they made wd-40 one brah cuz I mean
hell we could do anything with that you
know beautiful uh let's take another
call here actually you know if we got a
patreon question okay this is from
tourist Agner one of my favorite
Christmas movies is home alone what
would you do if you were home alone at
eight years old because you wished your
family away what kind of stuff would you
do knowing you're the man of the house
now
personally I watch every r-rated movie
available and go through everything in
every bedroom looking for treasures let
me think if I was while I was home all
the time when I was young I was home
alone all the time dude and I would
always I would have a couple extra
vanilla creams that was the first thing
because we was allowed to vanilla creams
at night for dessert and that's that
vanilla cookie vanilla cookie cream in
the middle white cream in the middle so
I'd have about probably about six or
eight of em matches and some milk you
know could we always have to split up
the milk we had we had to split up the
cookies so I would I would cheat man I
would have what I wanted and what else
so then sometime I like to take off my
shirt and pants and I like - we had a
couch and it three cushions I like to
lay under the cushions like on top of
the couch but under the cushions and
just like feel that pressure kind of
against my body and just look out from
the side you know from in between the
cushion and watch television like that
like a sandwich like I was a meat and
then the furniture was a breads and what
else would I do
oh I like to play game on the phone on
the television games would come up
sometime you know do you know sports
trivia or some call one eight eight
eight sports now and play the game
seventeen dollars a minute ninety
dollars if you're in Cuba you know
coupons don't apply or some kind of [ __ ]
so all we call that hotline I played
[ __ ] $200 worth of games at mama beat
my ass later with a bill King what else
did I do yeah we went peeking in our
mom's closet around Christmas that was
always so crazy man peaking in there you
know it made me realize how hard my mom
worked even just looking at her shoes
hanging from the shoe thing in the door
you know she had her heels and her work
shoes she had her morning walking shoes
these pink New Balances she had them
forever man they would probably they
were 20 years old when I met her you
know when she had
you know I don't know my mother was such
a hard worker man she was always going
she was always working hard I wish he
had told me hey I'm working hard so I
can take care of us because I think a
lot of time when I was a child I just
didn't know what was going on you know
no one ever said hey this is why this is
what's happening this is why we're doing
this
so sometimes today I'm always like I
always feel like I need to be doing
something I always feel like something
is wrong even though there's nothing
really you know I feel like somebody
pushed a car in the distance and have a
car loan and it's just going off outside
of the apartments or something but it's
and then all the alarms always been
there you know it just as always this
thing making me feel like something I
don't know what's happening like
everything is not okay
anyway I kind of dug rest and all that
here's a question from Jacob wells did
you believe in Santa growing up yes I
did and a lot of me still does you know
down in Covington Louisiana they used to
hire a it was like a small plane to go
through the air at night and they would
put a bunch of lights on it and stuff
and they would play Christmas music out
of speakers on it and so you could hear
on Christmas Eve you would actually be
able to take your kids outside and here
and here like a Christmas and see
something in the sky and I remember that
being a really neat treat for kids
because it just cement it into you that
Santa was there and you never even
thought he'll why the hell does Santa
have a propeller on his leg but you know
that's being a kid man
yeah let's take one more call here that
came in ninety five six six four nine
five zero three do you sup this is Bob
hey Bob thank you for calling brother oh
we're so lost my leg on a motorcycle
accident couple years back
damn Bobby that flamingos baby tell me
more
now I'm current fire
out how to get some [ __ ] poontang
with that stumpy here just you know kind
of hard not work you got to change up
the game so any thoughts thank you well
so you got that one you know you got
that one piece really rolling on rolling
on three right now and you looking for
love I think be forthright we're all
missing something you know we are all
missing something and I think these days
more than ever people that have you Nick
widdy's to them those things are valued
more than ever you know I used to know a
guy named Bob oh and he had cut off part
of his arm for some reason I don't know
why and it was below the elbow about
three or four inches so it was like in
his forearm and he would sometimes get
behind the bar at a bar or club and he
would walk and he would stick the the
nub part of this of his elbow and the
part coming forward a little bit of his
form up and he could turn him back and
forth like it was a submarine he would
walk up and down the bar and so if you
were like away from the bar about 15
feet you could see just this little
thing pop up and look around like it was
a submarine or a snork
remember the Snorks they were old
cartoon but yeah he had that Bob bow had
that submarine hitter and he was always
looking for cocaine really but he
beautiful man did and I still miss him
would you ask me oh man I think there's
more value than ever to be in unique
there's more value than ever them to
being unique and I said I know that's
easy for me to say cuz I'm bi right I
got my bipedal I got two hitters right
here below the belt but
but there's more now there's ways
constantly to inspire people they got
the titanium you could get something
graphite you could go wood even if you
know if if it's if it's a tough year
financially or if you're you know you're
living in like Newfoundland or something
you could get that wooden appendage
there's a lot of beautiful options out
there but I say be forthright eight
ladies
I got [ __ ] I got that magic wand you
feel me you know I'm that one-legged
[ __ ] I'm that stationary bad boy you
know all you got it man if you only have
one leg bro I love you dude
I think it's cool man you know I know
that's crazy but I think it's I think
it's really really cool because dude
when I see somebody that has a handicap
and they're really and they're
challenging it and they're man that
inspired me so much dude you know really
you have the chance to be so
inspirational to others and I know that
probably is hard to think about because
it doesn't heal what's going on but you
could hella get some puss bro they got
ladies out there that are [ __ ] some
real Muppets so I know when you come in
with that [ __ ] low body gonzo bro
that one piece all day bro you're gonna
be a you're gonna be a freaking third
lieutenant in the poontang mafia son and
I would decorate that leg bro get that
other leg decorated for the holidays bro
bro some [ __ ] lights around that
thing hang up hang up Oh a car freshener
off that [ __ ] man do something with it
dude I remember I was in Tucson Arizona
on the bus once and a man had a wooden
appendage of second half --lo half on
the left and he would sit on the bus
this one you could smoke cigarette on
the bus and he would put his across his
leg over the other leg and
the side of the wooden part he built him
ashtray in there and I was sitting there
one time with him having a cigarette
after work over there a city grill off a
tank averting Wilmont and I took the bus
and I'd sit there with him and have a
cigarette and put the ashes right out
into his leg and I've never forgotten
that oh we're at the end of the year
we're at the end of the year man and I
love you and you know if you need me
brah so I'll hold you up dog the more I
think about it man I will hold you up
you know I'll hold you up brother
and thank you for sharing what's going
on with you and your life man you're
holding me up gang [ __ ] bro we out here
dog and it's a beautiful time of year
and it's a beautiful time to love
somebody and it doesn't matter meat
means sex or anything like that are
touching yourself don't touch yourself
at Christmas what are you doing but
touch your heart man love yourself a
little get in there as that boy used to
say that had it and he had a lot of hits
of that tism and you know it what else
going on I may have this thing this week
chocolate shoulder challenge will put
out on instagrams you can check it out
remember get your Christmas shopping
done now it's almost over and I hope
your holidays are something special and
I hope that your heart is a fireplace
and and it keeps you warm and keeps the
others around you warm as well thank you
for three years thank you for the
support thank you for all the calls
you know this been one of the toughest
years of my life in some ways but I'm
feeling a little better and and I
couldn't be more grateful for you guys
not giving up on me I'm excited to see
you guys over in Lafayette I'm excited
to see you in Europe let's go I was
watching some rugby today likes to stir
in somebody else
let's go UK Manchester valasco do Blinn
London Oslo
I'm third am Norway let's go I can't
wait to get over there baby the Rat King
coming down your chimney January 4th we
start the tour over there
ari Manus the dirty little Hebrew
rolling over there with me so let's see
what we can do man you guys be good
yourselves I love you merry Christmas to
you and thank you thank you
let's take us out today with DJ dens the
rooster and Christmas Day sale
[Music]
[Applause]
just a little Christmas trap music
[Music]